ce soir nous allons terminer notre
émission en musique avec du slam avec
notre inattendue grand corps malade pour
son premier album midi 20 grand corps
malade
bonsoir alors ce grand corps malade a
une histoire
vous avez vous êtes né à saint denis
vous êtes né en 77 et puis vous êtes
vous destiniez à être professeur
d'éducation physique et vous avez eu un
accident j'ai eu un accident ou voilà où
je me suis cassé une vertèbre cervicale
et à la suite de ça j'étais je me suis
retrouvée heureusement momentanément
paralysé puis voilà j'ai bien récupéré
et voilà j'ai quelques c'est y aller et
quelques quelques parties du corps qui
reste à la traîne
vous en parlez dans votre texte vous
dites à un moment on dit à ma mère votre
fils ne remarchera plus ouais ben c'est
vrai voilà les médecins se sont un peu
précipitées pour le diagnostic et à la
base le diagnostic était très pessimiste
ben je suis content de les avoir fait
mentir alors quoi on parle un peu du
slam parce qu'on connaît pas forcément
alors je dire qu'est ce que c'est que le
slam ça dérègle ça passe à autant de
définitions de ce que des slameurs ce
que c'est ce que je dis est ce soit là
ya pas vraiment de définition du slam le
seul code à peu près qu'on peut
retrouver c'est que c'est le fait de
dire un texte a capella et puis aussi
ben voilà tout ce qui va derrière le
texte à dire l'émotion la tristesse la
joie l'humour et c'est un univers urbain
vi et une poésie urbaine s'est inséré
dans les villes vous c'est samedi par
exemple ouais enfin moi c'est juste un
slam urbain puisque voilà je viens de
milieux très urbain après ça veut pas
dire qu'on n'a pas le droit de cela mais
si on est à la campagne quoi c'est une
sorte de poésie moderne donc la mienne
et urbaine mais d'autres slameurs ce
sera pourquoi pas rural quoi ouais alors
quand on est là mais alors où est ce
qu'on se produit il ya des petits cafés
des endroits publics entre les copains
mais alors il ya tout un réseau comme ça
un petit peu
ouais il ya un vrai réseau en dorgogne
un vrai réseau
souterrains où il ya plein de petits
cafés pas forcément connus des fois tout
petit où il ya des scènes slam des
scènes ouvertes l'essence du slam c'est
ça comment on passe de la scène donc la
performance live à l'album
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il faut une
rencontre voilà six ans en une
succession de rencontres
j'ai d'abord rencontré un slameur qui
s'appelle s petit nico qui est entre
autres
voilà ce la mer mais aussi surtout
musicien compositeur et puis voilà on
avait cette petite démo de textes en
musique puis derrière j'ai rencontré un
jean rachid comédien qui est aujourd'hui
mon producteur
mais voilà par une succession de
rencontres se retrouve à avoir un disque
vous disiez trouve ça très sympa
il ya des gens importants alors on va
pas le dire mais sont ils son comptoir
ça fait un petit singe je ne connais pas
du tout je sais pas un garçon non
paraît-il
vous auriez participé à ce spectacle est
là merci
et qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce qui
ce qui s'est passé dernièrement ça il
s'est passé des choses violent et
particulièrement même sur cette place et
à saint denis comment vous l'avez vécu
vous de votre fenêtre au milieu des gars
bah je trouve ça voilà forcément grave
et triste
je suis pas un spécialiste de la
question politique du cpe et je suis pas
je suis jamais rentré dans le détail de
ce que de ce que proposait ce projet
mais je me sens forcément concerné parce
que parce que voilà le cpe ça concerne
pas mal de gens qui m'entourent et c'est
après dans le ciel peu faut choisir les
dés qu'on aime pas tu peux pas dire du
mal du cpe cas le sais c'est pas bien le
pc tu vas dire soit correct c'était une
blague
maintenant vous écouter vous avez je
crois a choisi un nouveau slam que vous
allez peut-être faire peut-être faire
debout ça marche alors s'est vu de ma
fenêtre et justement on en parlait et
qu'est ce qu'on voit de votre nez voilà
vu de ma fenêtre avec des bâtiments si
je te disais que je vois de la verdure
tu saurais que je mens et puis pour voir
un bout de ciel fausse punch et
franchement vu de ma fenêtre j'ai des
petits qui font du skate ça fait un
bruit tam à la tête
il ya des gars en bas qui galère ils
sont là ils font rien ils prennent l'air
surtout le printemps surtout l'été
surtout l'automne surtout l'hiver vue de
ma fenêtre j'ai vachement de passage de
carrefour à la mairie je vois des gens
de tout âge du métro à la boulangerie je
vois toutes sortes de visage je vous
premières loges pour les arrachages de
portable j'ai une vue très stratégique
si j'étais une cave j'aurai mon appart
comme planque aux flics vue de ma
fenêtre et le café de france juste en
bas de page il est tenu par des rebelles
je te jure ça s'invente pas il ya des
meufs bien coiffé qui viennent prendre
un café et des petits couples serein qui
viennent boire un coup avant d'en tirer
un et à des gentils poivrot qui viennent
oublier leurs galères dans la bière
surtout le printemps surtout l'été
surtout l'automne surtout l'hiver aux
beaux jours il met même des tables en
terrasse vue de ma fenêtre ya plein de
monde au soleil c'est la classe et comme
je vois tout de ma planche comme à kiev
mes potes m'appelle avant de venir pour
savoir s'il ya de la meuf une ma fenêtre
suggère le plus souvent c'est ludo il
est gentil mais quand tu le crois c'est
pas forcément un cadeau
si tu ne supportes pendant une heure je
te jure t costaud c'est le mec qu'on
appelle la cerise sur le ghetto vue de
ma fenêtre c'est pas de la télé réalité
ni un site comme d'hab et production et
je vois pas mal de gens qui triment et
voit la vie comme une sanction
et même si face à la galère ils
préfèrent se taire et met pas de genou à
terre et le poing en l'air il reste fier
surtout le printemps surtout l'été
surtout l'automne surtout l'hiver parce
que oui vu de ma fenêtre je vois pas mal
d'espoirs en jouant petit blond joue au
foot avec le petit noir quand je vois
des gens qui se bougent quand je vois
des gens qui se mettent des coups de
pied au cul pour sortir de la zone rouge
et pour que la vie vaille le coup d'être
vécue quand je vois ces deux hommes qui
boivent un coup ensemble en riant alors
qu'ils sont soit disant différent parce
que lundi shalom
elodie salam mais [ __ ] ils serrent la
main c'est sa lame de mon slam je prends
ça comme un bon signe
c'est peut-être un espoir infime mais je
te jure je l' ai vu c'est pas pour la
rime
bon c'est vrai que vu de ma fenêtre je
vois aussi la galère la misère les
suicidaires et les retours au pays en
charter je suis un [ __ ] de ravers
un grand optimiste c'est une philosophie
qui me suis alors je me dis que ça peut
s'arranger
j'espère donc je suis une ma fenêtre
avec des bâtiments si je te disais que
je vois de la verdure tu saurais que je
mens et puis pouvant aboutir il faut se
pencher franchement le vase il vient
chez moi on regardera par la fenêtre
tu comprendras pourquoi je rigole
pourquoi je crains pourquoi je rêve
pourquoi j'espère surtout le printemps
surtout l'été surtout l'automne surtout
l'hiver voilà moi je crois qu'on a on a
tous compris pourquoi on doit écouter
grand corps malade qu'on doit acheter ce
album je le regardais je l'ouvrais
j'avais envie qui les paroles s'est
passé il ya toutes les peurs et à tous
tes paroles et sont là voilà un petit
livret voilà moi c'est avant tout du
texte pour moi c'était important et à
16,16 text 16 morceaux il ya les paroles
des seize
voilà moi ça m'a fait très plaisir - moi
je dois dire tout simplement que pour
moi grand corps malade c'est sûrement
une des plus belle façon des plus
émouvants façon parler de la cité de la
banlieue et de tout le sud autre chose
je pensais que de ça parce qu'il parle
aussi de thèmes beaucoup plus universel
mais tu en parles si je peux me
permettre très bien merci beaucoup merci
daniel merci
[Musique]
rappel grand corps malade
12h20 alors n'a rien dit sur le titre
12h20 c'est pour tout un chacun j'ai
essayé d'imaginer que votre vie fait 24
heures et posez vous la question
il est quelle heure pour vous en ce
moment pour grand corps malade il était
12h20 alors cigale 15 et 16 mai ouais
c'est ça à moitié a cappella à moitié
avec des musiciens sur scène mais
toujours avec cette belle voix jeu sur
serre merci merci beaucoup
ce soir notre performance sera assurée
par grand corps malade à l'occasion de
la sortie de son album enfant de la
ville
grand corps malade si vous voulez me
retrouver c'est à l'olympia l'est 22 23
et 24 mai encore malade bonsoir bonsoir
morts jeudi et c'est vrai je suis très
très très heureux de vous retrouver
france et vu le 7 avril 2006 comme le
temps passe grand corps malade est
devenu grand merci beaucoup
il s'est passé beaucoup beaucoup de
choses ce premier album 700 militants
plaire l'olympia les les tournées mais
toujours détourné avec des retours à
saint-denis à la mjc pour assurer les
ateliers ouais toujours ce important on
a essayé de monter une tournée qui nous
permettait de ne pas être sur les routes
25 dates par mois et ne pas savoir quel
jour on est de ne pas savoir où on
habite donc du coup à chaque fois il y
avait de très nombreux retours à s'en
tenir pour continuer les activités
normales pour continuer d'animer des
ateliers slam avec des jeunes comme
comme tu dis aussi avec des retraités
ont fait du slam avec avec des seniors
des petites mamies ware est carrément sa
sas la mesure alors bon cette aventure
allait extraordinaire en plus quelque
chose qui doit faire plaisir
les textes et qui dit à l'école bah
c'est ben je suis très flatté de ça j'ai
appris que les profs de français qui se
servaient de mes textes comme ils ont pu
servir d'autres textes avant deux
rappeurs bissa donc je suis très content
que mes petits textes écrits sur ma
petite table se retrouve être étudié par
des élèves
et puis j'ai même appris que dans
certaines académies listées aux bateaux
français donc
donc c'est quand même un disquaire
absolument faramineux et on a alors
quand on fait le deuxième on n'a pas
l'impression de faire le plus dur là que
ça en fait moi je vais pas trop ressenti
comme ça parce que j'ai continué à
écrire très régulièrement je me suis pas
mis je me suis pas dit tiens ça il faut
que j'écrive un deuxième album
j'ai voyagé plein de textes que j'écris
régulièrement donc au long de tout au
long de ces deux années j'ai même
ressorti un ou deux textes qui étaient
antérieurs même au premier album donc du
coup voilà j'ai pas senti de pression
particulière en écrivant tout ça alors
il ya des textes un petit peu différent
je prends ça comme une évidence qu'il ya
un texte un très beau texte amoureux qui
dit la difficulté d'écrire quand on aime
vraiment c'est ça bah ouais c'est ça
déjà un parce qu'on n'ose pas trop se
livrer il ya les potes qui vont chambre
et tout ça et puis surtout parce qu'un
terrain d'un canard voit la fameuse
expression être un canard et puis aussi
parce que vrai comme jeudi d'un texte
n'a pas droit à l'erreur quand tu écris
un exam our tu veux pas faire un truc à
moitié il faut vraiment qu'ils soient
bourreau fonctions a réussi tu peux pas
de foire et sur un texte d'amour alors
vous l'avez dit vous ne souhaitez pas
être un porte parole ne vous sentez que
vous avez fait changer l'image du slam
dans l'opinion publique ou dans dans le
grand public ou manière non pas vraiment
je suis enfin le slam et c'est vrai que
c'était assez confidentielle c'était
c'était essentiellement dans des petits
bars loin de toute activité commerciale
donc c'est vrai que moi avec ce disque
back home j'ai été assez médiatisé et où
j'ai pu essayer de deux mètres le slam
en avant j'ai toujours essayé de le
projecteur qui était sur moi de le
dévier aussi sur le slam j'ai toujours
essayé d'expliquer vraiment ce qu était
le slam
parce que pour moi un disque c'est tout
sauf du slam c'est que c'est dans les
petits bars et le partage de la scène
c'est à capella donc voilà donc du coup
mais je sais que j'ai participé en tout
cas à le faire connaître au grand public
mais en tout cas voilà le slam a besoin
de personne pour continuer son petit
bout de chemin mais en tout cas il a été
un peu plus mises en lumière bon je sais
pas si le slam n'a pas besoin de grand
corps malade mais nous on a besoin de
grand corps malade on va alors on va
vous écoutez donc dans dans père et mère
avec plaisir à la alors s'il vous plaît
mesdemoiselles mesdames et messieurs
vous allez écouter je dis bien écouter
grand corps malade s'il vous plaît
bonsoir
alors je vous faire un texte qu'on est
entre slameur on appelle ça un texte
technique
ça s'appelle pervers depuis la nuit des
temps l'histoire des pères et des mères
prospère sans sommet récent faire
d'impair j'énumère pêle-mêle père mère
il ya des pères détestable et des mères
héroïque il ya des pères exemplaires et
des merdique
il ya des mères un peu père et des
paires maman il ya des pères
intérimaires et des permanents il ya les
pères imaginaire les paires fiction ou
bien les pères qui coopèrent à la
perfection
dd persévère et des mercenaires des
mères qui interdisait des permissions la
dpr nul et des mères extraordinaire ne
valent pas un père même si 10 percent en
mer sont du père c'est clair il ya des
pères et des beaux pères comme des
compères qui coopèrent oubliant les
commères et les langues de vipères il ya
les roms mère qui cherche des repères
refusant les pépères amorphe
mais les pauvres se récupère les experts
du divorce il ya les pères outre mer qui
foutent les glandes mammaires
les paires primaire les perfides les
personnels quand le mal de mer ce qui
laisse les maires vexés les perplexe moi
mon père et ma mère sont carrément hors
pair et au milieu de ce récit je prends
quelques secondes je tempère pour dire à
ma mère et à mon père merci il ya une
mère candy des impairs aimable il est le
maire régis des imperméables
il ya des pères absents et des mets
refusé il ya des maires présents tdp
refusé il ya des mères choyé et des mers
et mais il ya des perfusions et dépérit
mais il
mr intéresser la mer ville l'argent du
père en péril face à la mer quand il ya
les pensions alimentaires à les pères
crédit les pères du week end et dès
mercredi
il ya des péris perfore et des mères qui
positive où les coups de blues qui
perforent les mères sans perspectives
mais s'il est persécuté le père s'est
quittés et si la mère pleure c'est
l'enfant qui perd mais si la mère tu
l'amertume la magie s'éveille et au
final qu elle soit jeune ou vieille la
merveille
moi mon père et ma mère sont carrément
hors pair et au milieu de ce récit je
prends quelques secondes je tempère pour
dire à ma mère et à mon père merci il ya
les maires qui désespère à cause d amour
est perpétuellement à la recherche d'un
homme à perpète
il ya la mère célibataire persuadé de
n'être personne et qui attend dans ses
chimères que derrière la porte à
personne via les maires soumises et les
paires pulsions il ya les maires battue
et les percussions il ya les maires en
galère à cause des pervers des perturbé
alors il ya la mer qui se casse si elle
est perspicace
en revanche si le père et la mère
s'acoquiner vont se faire mettre si je
peux me permettre
la tension est à dix mille ans perd car
quand le père est en mer et que la mère
obtempère c'est la hausse du mercure car
le père percuté la mer permute le père
tant sa perche et la mercerie de cette
performance de ce perforant impertinent
telles sont les péripéties du père dur
face à l'éphémère
moi mon père et ma mère sont carrément
hors pair et à la fin de ce récit je
prends quelques secondes je tempère pour
dire à ma mère et à mon père merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]